ou alors vous le savez c'est parfois
12,2 pas faute doudoune de devenir une
star très jeune et beaucoup d'enfants
stars ont eu beaucoup de mal à faire une
belle carrière après parfois ça marche
très bien pour eux et ils arrivent à
poursuivre durablement une carrière et
gagner beaucoup d'argent on a voulu
faire un jeu très simple trouver les
cinq enfants stars les plus riches de
tous les temps et bien en cinquième
position
l'enfant star la plus riche de tous les
temps à votre avis c'est qui et bien je
vous le dis oui des écoles c'est britney
spears bravo matthieu delormeau britney
spears avec 215 millions de dollars
britney spears elle s'était fait
connaître dans le mickey mouse club
avant de vendre 34,5 millions d'albums
au cours de sa carrière
c'est la cinquième enfant star la plus
riche en quatrième c'est et rigueur
castelculier relègue justin timberlake
exactement 250 millions de dollars
comme britney il était membre du mickey
mouse club avant de trouver la gloire
avec le fameux boys band lensing partir
de deux enfants disney ouais exactement
il a ensuite résisté grâce à l'arrière
du bo sallanches jours et voilà en
troisième c'est qui las 305 dollars
viber michael jackson christina aguilera
c'est leonardo dicaprio il est apparu
dans diverses émissions de télévision
notamment going pence ça veut dire va
chercher du pain et dicaprio a lancé sa
carrière sur grand écran à 19 ans dans
what's eating gilbert grape qui a mangé
la grappe de gilbert moins de 160
millions de dollars
ensuite en deuxième position c'est
michael jackson et l'essor mary kate et
ashley olsen ces 500 millions de dollars
avant de gérer leur empire de la mode
les célèbres jumelles ont joué le rôle
de michel tanner dans la fête à la
maison fait les deux bien sûr que 87 à
95 et série que moi j'adorais l'afp m
le rer a et enfin numéro hince michael
jackson beurre du tribun michael chang
la droite et là je redis on dit
pour angie c'est une femme si elizabeth
taylor et whisky est apparue d'anvers
jouahri born every minute ça veut dire
il faut boire du minutes mail cédé 2 ans
à l'âge de 10 ans et devenu une icône
d'hollywood avec près de 80 films et
séries télé au cours de sa carrière
600 millions de dollars les enfants
stars et moyens pour répondre au sexisme
machin machin est à trois filles et deux
garçons exactement oui en plus sur la
carte ce qui est des chemins n'ya pas le
leader j'ai raté l'avion
les bras le petit nord malgré deux films
alcoolique hall qui n'ont un gars il a
juste raté l'avion docteur dit avery
pour un enfant d'être très riche très
jeune est-ce que ça ça peut être
dangereux très dangereux que la rive
d'un seul coup il perd le sens de la
mesure ça et il n'aura plus envie de
quoi ensuite
c'est très difficile parce qu'on va
c'est pour ça qu'ils perdent tous pis on
enlève ses rêves
ouais c'est ça c'est reconnaître lâcheté
peut tout y est c'est très dangereux
c'est très déstabilisant très profond
sillon jovelin je roule je vous le
confirme et relève et d'hystérie vous
savez ya la juriste jurisprudence jordi
maintenant l'argent est bloqué jusqu'au
18 ans des enfants ouais c'est vrai
exactement et bien ça permettait pas les
parents ne dilapide pas l'argent disent
que moi quand je me suis fait renverser
par un marchand glace j'avais
l'assurance me2 je devais me donnais 20
mille francs sur mon compte et ce
n'était pas bloquée par jordi mais par
exemple et les vingt mille fois que
j'avais tout avait été renversé par un
morceau d'os de vos amis qui me colle
dans le sang